so there's a lot of chaos going on and
we wanted to take a break in the middle
of it to tell you something happy dave
portnoy as a day job runs barstool
sports he's watched the country
get poorer he wanted to help he's now
raised tens of millions of dollars to
help small businesses stay alive during
these lockdowns
one of these small business owners
recently spoke to him by phone to
explain what that money meant to her
listen my whole body's numb right now
i'm glad we could help
you guys you guys are angels this is
we've been feeling so abandoned and so
scared about the future thank you so
much for
for taking care of the people that
have seemed to be forgotten so the rest
of us are arguing about how big the
checks could be
should be important i just decided i'm
going to do it myself and raises the
money and gives it to the people who
need it
kind of an amazing story you'd think it
would be everywhere it isn't
it's been pretty much ignored the
barstool sports fund by the media but
this week
some in the press start taking a
different approach they're angry
and they're trying to destroy barstool
sports the san francisco chronicle for
example is a garbage paper
wrote the woman you just saw was quote
not aware of portnoy's history of making
racist and misogynistic remarks
or the accusations of sexual harassment
against him
because no good deed goes unpunished
apparently dave portnoy
joins us tonight first of all dave you
did it
i knew that you would i think it's a
really moving story it's a great story
um why aren't more people celebrating it
we're starting to pick up steam but uh
who knows there's agendas it's sad i
mean obviously they come on this show so
you get painted with a certain brush
which i'm right here you're aware
uh you know we're just trying to help
people we're just trying to help people
uh i don't care whether democrat
republican left right
green yellow black white there's people
and they need money
and these videos that we're doing show
it and i'll go anywhere tucker you
invite me you help launch it
but i will literally going anywhere so
the credit today show did a very nice
piece on it helped us
um so you know this is one of those
issues
that i'm glad we're helping but the fact
that anybody can't be
this should be there should be nobody
who has you know anything against it
this is just
people helping people in the truest
sense and we are getting
there's 20 million dollars we're close
to 21 million we've had people reach out
but why you know fox has been great
promoting it they have
um but everybody should because the more
publicity we get
the more small businesses we can help
and it spans everywhere
so i don't have that answer i'm just
focused
get publicity get money get it to the
people who need it
now you guys are really successful i
don't think you're quite as big as
blackstone or goldman sachs i won't make
you answer but i mean where are their
funds
by the way seriously the people who are
getting you know where's jeff bezos's
fund a
sincere question like what the hell why
is this left to you to do
you run a sports site like what is this
i i have no idea i will say and we're
just getting ready to tweet it i'm happy
to say elon musk
uh is gonna help us so i think that will
go a long way
but i don't know um maybe they don't
know about it i don't know what they do
listen it's that's almost in a weird way
the trauma of what we're doing
is just everyday people across every
walk of life
reaching out unsolicited saying can i
give you fifty dollars can i give you a
hundred thousand dollars
they just want to help and it is the
beauty of this country there's so much
chaos i don't get it bad but there's a
lot of good this country is still great
that's right
there's people who want to help that's
exactly right and that's why i was
excited to talk to you tonight
what kind of people you've been giving
the money to
it's all walks we literally get all
walks of life but
small business restaurants uh bar owners
dry cleaners you name it it's touch
and it not surprisingly the states that
have the strictest lockdowns of
california new york massachusetts
a lot of applicants from those states
but these are people
who have been in business that first
woman that's the oldest bar
west of the mississippi in san francisco
it's been around since 1830
it's their life brand they put
everything into to lose
a bar like that and have nobody pay
attention
that's why these people are breaking
down it's for the first time that
finally you see we've been here for 200
years
it's sad it's sad
it's just crushing and you are making a
difference i never say that because it
sounds so dopey but actually you are
and i'm grateful i know they are too
dave important thank you
thanks